it grabbed headlines sparked polarizing
debates and caused the stir at home and
all the way across the Atlantic the new
American president executive order
temporarily banning travelers from seven
muslim-majority countries from entering
the US has raised serious concerns in
the EU no one can beat the price of his
or her own right because of their place
of birth the religion or the ethnicity
and I'm worried by the transfer is
seeing inside the American societies in
this place with political rhetoric
already causing deep social divides any
PS did not hold back on the criticism
expressing worry that the u.s. band
further fuels Nana phobic sentiment
America is English did lunch the Friars
which are eigen Atlanta in ventura and
yes general photography next rotten can
also dr. internet religion schemin shows
they finished 24 inches apart honest
description Olympus elna bugia demagogue
chica C fiber novella cool apparently no
Connie quali drum the bass vari since
1975 no American has been killed on US
soil by a national from any of the seven
countries listed in present from
executive order Trump's maneuvers have
struck a chord as lawmakers find
themselves on the same page descending
Europe core values we can do one thing
that is United fight back as the
European Union it is not because he is
elected that he can go against human
values